so many people do try and do teenage
characters
i think it's impossible to nail and
uh and then bailey is just
and when i watch her it almost gets
under my skin
it's so accurate as you guys know i'm
currently
quarantining by choice not because i
like
have corona or whatever but yeah mostly
because like my parents
are being awkward they're like doing
that like push-up challenge
and my dad like has a v now
so i'm like staying in my room did you
just watch a ton of teenagers for a
while before you attempted that
character
or did you just always know how to do
bailey i
i think i always knew how to do her
because i think it's um
it's always lived inside me like i i was
always the type who
like you know would like kind of hide
behind her hair
and like um you know make you
feel weird for even existing like you
know she would probably be like
hi conan like thanks for having me on
your show
or whatever i don't i don't watch it
like i mean my dad like says you're a
genius but
like sorry i don't like watch it and
then you just feel so
bad about yourself yeah yeah no it's
funny
uh i mean i don't think i'm over
analyzing it but her discomfort
weirdly about herself somehow makes
anyone she's talking to uncomfortable
yes and that's what i think
um teenagers do like they they
make you feel like you shouldn't exist
at all yeah and then the other thing you
do
that i absolutely love as bailey is
you'll be talking and everything's fine
and then your mood shifts
completely and it's
hilarious and also frightening because
it's
so accurate you'll just go from happy
to in the depths of the most
soul-crushing despair i know and it's
like soul-crushing despair that
now after we've lived like adult lives
is so
not a big deal but like to a young
i remember i remember when brad pitt
didn't get nominated for legends of the
fall
like to my mom i was like
this is a problem like just
it was my whole week like and give us
that i like wish like that still right
right